##
-I'm madly in love with you.
-Too bad.
-Is there someone else?
-Yes.
He is Death.
Emily has a wild imagination,
and Death is someone
she's in love with.
And he is played by
none other than Wiz Khalifa.
-Nice to see you.
-You were late.
KHALIFA:
Emily's infatuated with death.
She's not scared of it.
He's more like a inspiration.
I think she's so attracted
to me, 'cause I'm mysterious.
-But he always takes so long.
-I'm busy.
We were thinking about hip-hop
as its relation to poetry
in a way that was fresh
and cool and a little dangerous.
So we needed Death to be
the coolest person ever.
-And Wiz, just, he's that.
-[laughing]
You are such a weirdo.
Why am I so attracted to you?